absolutely a hundred percent male
identified no matter what else occurs in
their life
that's why
i'm like in that space you think it's
right you have to give him some props
because he knows she's talking [ __ ]
yeah and he's just like i've gotta get a
set are you done the lead attorney talks
about how if someone's being crazy you
have to like not let your face change
because like you want to let them keep
going yeah yeah yeah and hang themselves
basically yeah
he can't hide it
that's not correct
so what does gender affirmation care
you're a big proponent of if we walk
through a child
who's sitting down with you is
questioning yeah their gender what's the
gender affirmation process
affirmation means that as a pediatrician
as someone who says my job is to provide
the best medical care for you
is i need to listen really carefully and
how i put it in words for kids so that
they can understand it is tell me your
story
where have you been in terms of your
gender and your gender identity
how would your son respond to that tell
me your story he'd probably tell me a
story
he'd just be like all right so yesterday
i was with my friends and we were
tell me your story that's a that that's
like that's a
that's a statement you ask an adult you
don't ask a child that question well
cause they don't even know
like what are
i mean it's funny i haven't been around
like a ton of kids in a while because i
grew up but i grew up like around
because i have nine siblings you know so
there's always like a child in the house
and like the difference in your brain
between when you're 9 and 15 is like
crazy you're a completely different
person so how are they gonna have
someone make a decision at nine that
would have
it would affect the rest of their life
um
and that's the thing you're allowed to
do something that can affect the rest of
your life at that age but you're not
allowed to smoke not allowed to drink oh
yeah
but you can change your whole gender
okay do you know what i was doing when i
was 10
going
i was obsessed with japan i wanted to be
japanese
you could have had um
you could have been transracial i could
i yeah i was wearing kimonos
at the mall
and just like for fun because i thought
japan was going to do that language i i
didn't learn the language but i
memorized no i memorized some um some
what do you call it there's a
a movie that had some japanese in it and
i just memorized like the lines in the
movie and me and my friends would say it
back and forth to each other at the mall
kids kids that's what kids do youtube is
cool
i'm sure you thought you were cool no i
am i'm like so cool i was in terms of
your gender and your gender identity
where are you right now
and more excitingly where would you like
to be in the future
have you ever met a four-year-old
who believes in santa claus
says to someone who believes that
a fat man is traveling through the sky
and a flying reindeer at lightning speed
coming down his chimney with presence
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle on the reality that's very real
for them agreed agreed but santa claus
is real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real
and but santa claus does deliver their
christmas presents
see
see
see
to that child
they are so what she's saying is
you can create your own reality in your
head and if you believe it
it's true
that's why you can't argue with these
people but that's why people have like
schizophrenia and stuff like that they
create a world in their head and they
believe that they are going through all
of these things and this is why they get
medicated
because
doctors know that that's actually not
reality what these people are doing is
saying okay the reality that you've
created in your head
yeah we'll make that your reality it's
crazy
it's actually insane and
oh my gosh because i don't know how you
could be this old like this is an old
lady and still believe that like i'm 25
you know what i mean i'm like manosphere
gold you know
she's got a primate
25 and childless i'm almost going to hit
my wall someone's going to
step you up soon you would think right
but but but no and i feel like at 25
i have a better grasp on reality than
this old lady yeah how should it be
unfortunately this shouldn't be
well yeah but he's not real though
to that child they are
when i see a child who you know believes
in santa claus and then let's say this
is a boy and he says i'm a girl
this is someone who can't distinguish
between fantasy and reality so
how could you take that
as a reality i would say that as a
pediatrician and as a wait she's wait
wait she's a pediatric oh my god i
forgot she was a doctor
i totally forgot in this interview she
was a doctor because
she seemed so dumb she has to be someone
but she just constricted herself because
she said i would say how wonderful my
child's imagination is
so she's actually acknowledging
it's in here
i didn't even catch that
because your imagination isn't it
so she's just acknowledged that it's in
the head
but i'm sure she'll still try and
justify it i would say how wonderful my
four-year-old in their imagination is
male gametes that's what makes me male
no your your sperm don't make you male
then what does
it's a constellation
in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no
you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does a chicken have gender identity does
a chicken cry okay but but these are the
same people that are gonna say like men
should cry the same as women and that
there's there's no difference between
male and female like the way we dress
like i said the other day
the whole thing is confusing because
like i was saying lesbians are women on
women
i can be a woman that means i can be a
lesbian that means you can be a gay man
maybe i am there you go you could be a
gay man the whole thing is just crazy
it's not making any sense or they'll say
like men can wear dresses
like the outfits don't make it which
basically is saying that dresses aren't
meant for men
they're meant for women but then they
can't art they can't answer what is a
woman
it's it's too it's too confusing though
it's too confusing
i forget people like this exist
sometimes because people around me are
pretty sane right so sometimes i forget
i would love to have her on my show i
would i would love a conversation with
her as well yeah she can commit suicide
let's reframe it because you're talking
you're trying chicken has sex like any
like any biological organisms an
assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign female to chickens
when they lay eggs that's it we assume
they're female if they lay eggs
at what age does the medical transition
begin with uh medication so medical
affirmation begins when the patient says
they're ready for it
so that could be
a kiddo who is just starting puberty
and panicking because they're getting
breast buds or their penis is getting
bigger and busier and they're worried
about all kinds of masculine changes and
that way puberty blockers which are
completely reversible
and
don't have permanent effects are
wonderful because we can put that pause
on puberty just like if you were
listening to music you put the pause on
and we stopped the blockers and puberty
would go right
back to where it was the next note in
the song
just
what's that please spell they're messing
with your whole biology biology
this is what's so sinister about it for
me is that human beings have a biology
and the fact that they're going to stop
a natural process within every human
being says that there's something wrong
well and she can't not know that there's
going to be effects
like there has to be side effects from
that i'm not a doctor i don't have a
biology degree but it's just common
sense if you delay puberty there's going
to be side effects from that that'll
probably last them the rest of their
lives like as we said earlier on how can
a child at the age when they start to
like when they start puberty how can
they know that this is a decision that
they want until they're in their 60s no
they don't there are decisions that i
made in my 20s i'm like what a stupid
decision yeah you know what i mean it's
child abuse i think
i think it is i think it's yeah i think
any parent that allows that is literally
i would say child abuse 18 you can do
what you want
but you're going to do that at 13 14 9
10. i was i thought i was japanese at
13. i said my son was sonic the hedgehog
yeah what the hell